hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu entwickeln die das spiel was wir
heute spielt heißt angry birds das ist
angry birds in m lg tatsächlich wir
können hier links einfach mal auf
englisch drauf klickt dann hier auf die
eins und dann sind wir
ich werde nicht mehr wir können jetzt
hier diese mountain view it sachen
nehmen und die hier hinten in das
gebäude ein brettern
ich habe es auch schon geschafft mann
ich weiß nicht ich ahne ich muss diese
komischen dreieckig abschießen
jetzt sind wir auch schon im level 2 und
können jetzt im level 2 übrigens sorry
falls es mit dem total behämmert ist
aber ich kann den sound von spiel nicht
abstellen und kann deswegen auch keine
hintergrundmusik hinter packen und das
ist alles tut mir leid aber das ganze
video scrap ich schieße und jetzt
einfach mal die laserschwerter weg
klasse ich hatte übrigens selber man
laserschwert dann hab ich's kaputt
zerbrochen es kate zockt war hier das
ist ein youtube kumpel von mir und wir
haben gedacht hey kann man das
kaputtmachen und ja man kann alles
kaputtmachen das ist eine andere
geschichte ich mache jetzt erstmal hier
ein bisschen über den garten schreppel
klug gefällt auf jeden fall auch und wir
haben schon wieder gewonnen
bald kommt ihr sogar ein englisches film
in die kinos habe ich gelesen dass ist
ja auch kräftiger warum nimmst du dir
nicht das dreieck damit man erstmal nach
ganz hinten um die da hinten weg zu
klatschen
warum geht das hier nicht kaputt planen
einfach komplett nach hinten sondern
haben wir den jackpot confirm was ist
das hier für eine scheiße mann und den
mache ich jetzt trick schott über die
decke ich kann so was richtig gut kann
ich den baum da irgendwie abschießen
nein es geht definitiv nicht
ich hab doch alle getötet meine fresse
hallo youtube falls leute von euch dann
aber das ist nicht wahr als leute von
euch dieses video sehen sollten bitte
sperrt ist nichtig als ob das da schon
wieder drauf liegt man jetzt schaffe ich
habe es geschafft ich hoffe dass das
video von julio gott das hier sieht aus
wie ein master level ich hoffe dass das
video von youtube auf grund der mutter
nicht gesperrt wird falls es das doch
wird dann sehen wo mein gott macht noch
mehr einblendung alter hier sind jetzt
beim master level ich weiß nicht ob das
jetzt besonders schwer ist oder ob ich
das einfach wieder mit meinem kompletten
spiel hier schon wieder gewonnen
das spiel einfach zu gut weil bisschen
angst gesperrt wegen der musik deswegen
weil mein gott das internet explorer
töten wenn das sich also nicht mehr da
ist jetzt gerade nicht wie sie sind die
nicht tot okay ich hab jetzt glaube ich
ihnen den besonderen vogel ich probier's
mal irgendwie kommt also tot ich glaube
ich kann mit diesem vogelschießen ich
weiß allerdings nicht genug probleme
es geht definitiv nicht jetzt auf den
internet explorer drauf wieso geht denn
jährlich kaputt machen kann sein dass
man den internet explorer einfach nicht
töten kann weil er einfach auch so
totales charakter mein gott nein was ein
crash meist eine andere taktik und mache
erstmal den hier unten irgendwie klappt
jetzt rollt die mountainbiker kommen
snoop dogg jetzt habe ich denen noch
kaputt gemacht und jetzt gleich nämlich
nämlich den internet explorer weg und
das illuminaten dreieck in dem ich so
schieße der internet explorer geht
einfach nicht kaputt holliger und fliegt
denn ich habe zwei auf einmal getötete
internet explorers mac und das dreieck
das heißt ich habe jetzt die chance
jeden den hierbei sollte es dennoch weg
you can do it vogel common gewonnen nein
zwei auf einmal wieder weg wie haben nur
noch diese beiden dreiecke alter das
muss jetzt klappen das erste dreieck ist
weg und jetzt nehmen wir den blauen
vogel oder sonic oder sonic oder wer das
auch immer ist und neben diesen vogel
und schließen das zweite dreieck ab
wir sind eigentlich ganz froh mein gott
wir haben eine nuklear raketen
ist explodiert ich mache wieder eine
taktik die war spitze ich hab nur noch
eine flasche mountain view jetzt da oben
gegen das die genau da und jetzt das
auch irgendwie dass nur noch das land
platte ist übrigens schau die rakete
diesmal direkt da oben gegen das direkt
nach unten fliegt und jetzt geschafft
ich sah das spiel gar nichts gegen mich
machen level neu das jetzt einfach mal
hier das letzte level weil das video
schon sehr lang geht weil ich so viele
versuche gebraucht habe ich wieder alle
auf einmal getötet ich habe jetzt mal
was das geld hier oben um ich weiß nicht
ob ich das auch noch irgendwie tut mein
gott als ob ich die alle töten muss man
das ist die letzte flasche mountain view
wie ich heute abschließen werde
das level ist unmöglich auch nicht
spaßig beete das video an dieser stelle
weil ich ultra müde bin man sieht mir
glaube ich die augenringe echt schon an
führt mich in eine bewertung freuen
falls sie mehr von solchen benannten
spielen haben wollt dann schreibt auch
gerne in die kommentare und wir sehen
uns im nächsten video wieder